virtue signaling as a term became very
common around 2016 with the Trump versus
Clinton election and it was often used
by conservatives to make fun of leftist
people preaching at everybody but not
actually doing very much good right so
there's a negative cheap Talk version of
virtue signaling virtue signaling can be
extremely positive if you got two single
people and they're searching for mates
and they meet up and they have a date
they're trying to evaluate each other's
ethical compass and their personality
traits like how agreeable how
compassionate is this person they'll
talk about all kinds of things that
basically boil down to Virtue signals
but some of those might actually be
reliable indicators so it is actually
some kind of good signal of underlying
values and personality traits